Y eso sí los indicadores los bancos y el
mundo de las finanzas no da tregua a
pesar de los días de descanso Jorge
bienvenido de vuelta otra vez aquí en
directo a América Comencemos hablando de
las perspectivas económicas que hay para
la región y para el mundo Bueno una
previsión del ritmo de crecimiento más
débil en casi tres décadas eso dice el
Banco Mundial en su último informe que
fue publicado precisamente hoy el Banco
Mundial recortó las proyecciones y ahora
dice que la economía global se crecerá
solamente uno coma siete por ciento en
2023 y 2,7% en 2024 el pronóstico es una
fuerte desaceleración del crecimiento y
las previsiones son a la baja para casi
todas las economías avanzadas y casi del
70% para los mercados emergentes y en
desarrollo el organismo Santiago
advierte que dada la frágiles
condiciones económicas cualquier
acontecimiento adverso Como por ejemplo
una fuerte inflación aumento bruscos de
los tipos de interés o un rebrote mismo
de la pandemia así como el aumento de
las tensiones geopolíticas podría ser el
detonante para que la economía mundial
entre en recesión dijeron que esto
podría marcar la primera vez en 80 años
que dos recesiones globales ocurren en
la misma década después de Europa
América Latina es la región que menos
crecerá en el mundo en 2023 los motivos
principalmente sus micros comerciales
que deja la región expuesta a la
desaceleración de las economías
avanzadas y al debilitamiento de China
que reduciría por supuesto las
exportaciones Jorge lo estamos
mencionando en el bloque de noticias que
el gobierno del presidente Manuel en
Francia presentó ese plan de reforma
para las pensiones Bueno uno de los
puntos más delicados es la propuesta de
subir progresivamente la edad mínima de
jubilación que pasaría de los 62 a los
64 años al año 2030 el plan incluye una
aceleración el aumento hasta 43 años a
partir del 2027 del tiempo de cotización
que es necesario para disfrutar de una
jubilación completa también que la
pensión mínima suba a casi 1200 euros ne
al mes desde este año la jubilación es
un tema importante en Francia y la
reforma será una prueba importante para
el presidente macron en un momento en
que crece el descontento social sobre
todo por la inflación y el alto costo de
la vida según un sondeo de la octe
cuatro de cada cinco ciudadanos se
oponen al aumento de la edad de
jubilación Francia cuenta con una de las
edades de jubilación más bajas del mundo
industrializado y gasta más que la
mayoría de los países en pensiones casi
el 14% de la producción económica según
la ope y mire Japón casi en los 70 años
ya es el que lidera hablemos ahora del
presidente de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos sobre esas decisiones
para el 2023 que dijo bueno en un
discurso que pronunció en Suecia Powell
señaló que estabilizar los precios exige
tomar decisiones difíciles que pueden
ser Incluso impopulares políticamente el
discurso no dio pista así directa sobre
Hacia dónde va a dirigir la política del
banco central de Estados Unidos este año
que subió los tipos de interés siete
veces en 2022 para un total de 4,25
puntos porcentuales lo más relevante
Powell afirmó que serán inapropiado
utilizar las herramientas del Banco
Central para objetivos climáticos
escuchemos parte de su declaración
el público Espera razonablemente que los
supervisores exijan que los bancos
comprendan y puedan gestionar
adecuadamente sus riesgos materiales
incluidos los riesgos financieros del
cambio climático pero sin una
legislación explícita del Congreso sería
inapropiado que utilizáramos nuestras
herramientas de política monetaria o de
supervisión por ejemplo para promover
una economía más verde o para alcanzar
otros objetivos basados en el clima no
somos ni seremos responsables de la
política climática
Jorge hablemos de eso recientes anuncios
hechos durante la compra de Norteamérica
que tiene lugar en Ciudad de México los
líderes de Canadá Estados Unidos y
México hablaron de temas económicos y
comerciales así bueno los presidentes se
reúnen este lunes martes y miércoles en
Ciudad de México para celebrar la Cumbre
de líderes de América del Norte México
anunció la creación de un comité para
avanzar en la integración económica de
Norteamérica el grupo estaría destinado
a la planeación y sustitución de
importaciones para procurar hacer cada
vez más autosuficientes y para según
ellos el desarrollo y la cooperación y
el bienestar de los tres países se dijo
que cada país va a proponer a cuatro
especialistas para conformar este comité
que incluye a funcionarios públicos y
también a empresarios por su parte el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
centró su intervención en la importancia
de que las tres naciones unan esfuerzos
para mejorar las condiciones de sus
economías para el cierre la cifra del
día la cifra es Diez mil millones de
dólares eso invertiría Microsoft en chat
gpt este Esta es la Inteligencia
artificial de openenae de concretarse
esta inversión Open enaninai rondaría
una inversión de capital de riesgo por
casi 30.000 millones de dólares esta
empresa que cuenta con el respaldo del
respaldo económico de elon musk gana
dinero sobre todo cobrando los
desarrolladores por licenciar su
tecnología Muchas gracias Jorge por este
avance de los temas destacados de la
economía a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]